hey everybody and welcome to a
phenomenal wild ride with stevo there's
no other way to describe this week's
guest but phenom that's what he is man
it's patty the baddie and you don't even
have to be a ufc fan to know patty the
baddie is turning the world upside down
and this podcast with patty the baddie
is saving the world why
well
because we're teamed up with established
titles and they have this killer thing
it's an important scottish custom where
landowners are referred to as
lords and ladies and established titles
is a project that allows you to buy as
little as one square foot of dedicated
land to make you an official lord or
lady and what's even better is that they
are committed to planting a tree for
every single order i mean come on
planting all these trees saving all of
this land to be dedicated to just
keeping it
land
that's saving the world that's why this
is so much fun plus you get a killer
certificate framed to put on your wall
to brag about how you are a lord or a
lady and another reason to hurry up is
the killer labor day sale they're having
save the world and be awesome
so
if you hurry up and are one of the next
uh one of the first two or three hundred
something around there
the first two or three hundred people
are going to get their plot of land
right next to mine baby so hurry up man
go to established
titles dot com slash stevo they give you
10 off your order if you do that you
save the world you have your plot of
land right next to mine you're a lord or
a lady and did i mention you're saving
the world so haul ass to
establishedtitles.com
to save the world and become an awesome
lord or lady
now let's get into it dude when we walk
through there there's a speed bag
i want to
show you some [ __ ] on there nice now
that you see though
hey let's close that door i got it god
thanks vinny and we're recording so
yeah dude
we are not here to waste your time
brother
i'm good luck all right i've got
something to chill
all right
ladies and gentlemen
patty the baddie hamlet
how are we
dad do you want some drinks right there
yeah yeah i'd love some water that's
what's the philosophy of an avoiding
sparkling water it's just kind of
sparkling water by ours as we say tories
think that
conservatives drink sparkling water oh
[ __ ] so i hear that all about the labor
party yeah
torrey's drink that's interesting you
know about a little bit
you know like this the same really
aren't they know what i mean yeah
they're all the same
it's become considerably less about
ideology or political party than just
simply rich or poor yeah literally
yeah well the world's [ __ ] we know
that anyway and that's why i got a
vasectomy
i'm
me
i'm not [ __ ] you dude i don't want
to have kids
yeah
so man thank you for this i i appreciate
it no it's my pleasure yeah we met uh
first at the the arena at the ufc san
diego yeah then we just randomly
happened to both be at mike tyson's
studio that was funny though well this
is just a man again then with the mike
dyson on his arm he's [ __ ] crazy mud
yeah he's having the time of his life
him dad it's it's it's great when we
were at the the ufc san diego the the
fight was going on and like the fight
was over and the guy like raised his
hand like he acted like he was winning
and then the whole [ __ ] crowd was
cheering hysterically and like the guy
thought everybody was cheering for him
and then and then everybody looks over
and you're walking in felt terrible you
know it was it was when the it was in
the theater the fight the fight's still
on and i walked in
and everyone started screaming and i'm
like touching people's hands not as a
walking touching people down and then i
get to me seated i'm like haha last that
all them fighters are fighting and
[ __ ] people are screaming screaming
for me and then literally
the fighters are getting [ __ ] the
fight's getting maybe official and
everyone starts saying you know party
these fighters feel bad enemy managers
went to me what are you doing you don't
have to stand up everyone's shouting and
he was like
just got up
yeah yeah that's such a different take
on it than uh
than i perceived it as like like yes do
you make a valid point it was an awful
time to steal the moment of the fighters
yeah that was in the cage i mean they
just fought three hours four rounds yeah
i never thought of that all i could
think the only thing in my mind was
holy [ __ ] this [ __ ] guy patty the
baddie walks into the arena he's not on
the screen you know like there's no way
to be like you know it's one thing
because the whole arena can see the
screen so when they show someone in the
stand the whole place will cheer but in
this case patty was not on the screen he
just walked into the building and
because he was like that the whole
[ __ ] place starts chanting oh patty
the bad and i'm thinking this kid is the
biggest [ __ ] star that we've seen in
a long time man like out of the gate and
i had to go run over
to ask him for a photo dude and i
totally did and i posted it and then we
were dming on instagram yeah he's the
greatest so we were both on uh your
episode of the mike tyson hot boxing
podcasts what a [ __ ] show that was
[Laughter]
why you say that i think that uh that
guy mike tyson's
co-host for that episode like i don't
think he's ever even watched a single
fight
ever like i mean it just was asking some
questions that he had like pre-prepared
questions that were written down that it
just felt kind of awkward that he was
asking and then there was me i was
just on one dude yeah
you was a he's an mma aficionado that
was an easter egg yeah he was he watches
he watches the prelims prelims yeah
the fight pass preliminary i don't miss
a fight
but here's here's why i was so not
scared is that i got the surgery to get
the hardware out of my collarbone the
day before and like i'm a clean and
sober guy like i don't uh do drugs and
drink
for the last 14 years i've not been as
[ __ ] up on drugs as i just somehow got
off the general anesthesia from this oh
yeah
when i i've had
i've had this surgery i could probably
go back on my phone and find it but
after me surgery one time i'll never
forget put put on
doing this with me i'm putting the phone
there on video pressing video and going
i mean i'm just flopping what i mean and
i remember being in bed it was when i
got this undone actually because i've
had three wrist surgeries two on that
one one on this one this was the latest
one
kind of lying in bed
and
my the double bed i had in my mum's
house this one was living in me mums was
it was quite low to the floor i remember
just like rolling over and just stared
and dumped
and being like what the [ __ ] was that
noise and i couldn't feel it but my hand
was on the floor now after gentle
understanding you can't feel nothing in
your arm my arm is just on the floor
just like what if i had to pick my arm
up and put it back in bed and roll over
like you don't don't feel it for like it
wasn't it was like what you're
describing is just like being able to
feel your arm i'm talking about like it
[ __ ] flipped a switch on me that need
not be flipped like it just turned me
into a raving
[ __ ] out of control guy on drugs what
did they give you i don't notice that
was exactly my question what did they
give you then i gotta believe that it
was just propofol standard issue general
anesthesia which i've had
time and time again i've had so many
maybe they gave me more like maybe
something maybe i just somehow reacted
to it differently but but uh for all my
procedures that i had general anesthesia
it's never
done that to me and i just went kind of
bonkers and i couldn't sleep and i was
all [ __ ] acting crazy all night and
then like i got to go do this tattoo in
the morning i still hadn't [ __ ] slept
when i saw you at the mike tyson i still
hadn't slept and i was still frankly out
of my [ __ ] mind like uh yeah it just
didn't work
yeah that's what i was saying to him i
was like it's not it wasn't like it
didn't even look like he hadn't slept
well how about that yeah i was wondering
what his whoop strap recovery was when
he did that
recovery
what was your recovery last night when
you woke up this morning do you know it
was it was pretty it was all right that
i only done one session yesterday he saw
me i got enough for you know sometimes
it records me sleep wrong no one says
i've woke up at this time and i know
i've woke up an area i mean
yeah you could change that but i'm
because i'm just curious about like you
know your last nightmare is 85
85 is that normal um that's high 70 the
day before yeah let me go back a bit but
like dude
before i slept really well
and i don't get it because i'm like i
had some oh yeah you need to change it
from on the sleep you can change it to
get by
so i've changed my hands i get by you've
got yours on like the highest one made
it once you said i'm [ __ ] crazy
amounts of sleep what do you mean if you
do this
you buy
it's got three different settings on the
sleep and get by is like the lowest one
and just like get by on the amount of
sleep so it has my sleep as light as
like i don't need as much sleep
that's funny you can change it because i
if i still had it on that i'd always be
in bed i was i'm in therapy and the
therapist goes you know you're just the
get by guy
when he said get by i'm like i'm gonna
just get back
outside
no damn so excited you're putting on a
brand new whoop strap
yeah i mean dude it's a game changer for
my like recovery and health when you're
like training for a ufc fight like are
your levels just off the charts it's
just ridiculous in in like a goal behind
show you that that's some of the [ __ ]
that's what's so crazy about the womb
strategy is that when you're doing the
right thing when you're taking care of
yourself and you're eating right like
the numbers actually show you that
you're taking care of yourself i am
some days like you've been like 5 000
calories underneath yeah and what's your
strain for a day like when you're
working out for 20
ones really i mean yeah dude yeah like
do you ever work out so hard like close
to like bedtime that you can't sleep
because your heart's just jacked no
normally i'll be honest i normally get
most of my sessions done in like the
morning in the daytime i try and get all
my done before before the night when you
say a session like that that can mean a
lot of things right yeah definitely
every morning i go to the next gen me
gym back home on a scene for two hours
first so i'll do ten ten till twelve out
of a spa days when i spa i go going a
little bit early and it pads with on me
coaches alice this is when you're not in
a camp
yeah um when i mean comp
like you camp or not camping yeah
when i'm in the pool i'm saying every
day
you train year round whether you're in a
camper
even when you've you've put on all the
weight after your fight you're still
yeah it's not saying like i've seen this
one and a half nine and five forty
around the corner
yeah like even though i'm from about 200
pounds still going insane
you're about 200 pounds yeah dude that's
so crazy i had this idea right because
i've uh
just got addiction [ __ ] issues like
like the first she was drunk
like
i i've been i've flooded i've had party
days on what i mean like yeah i've been
bad then then i got into a bit of a
gambling and i was bad with that right i
think now others moved on to food no
what i mean i really no i'm not messing
i genuinely think i'm a food i
think i've got a little bit i think i've
got a bit of an eating disorder because
of because of mma
really
cuts out the weight cuts diet and i just
i really genuinely think i've had a bit
of an eating disorder because that times
like this now i just will see it later
because we're going to watch the ufc
later tonight yeah if there's food in
there
you will be like
she's still eating what i mean people
like when they go and eat with me
they're like
they're like
visibly shocked
what's your favorite cheat meal oh they
got asked this all the time and i can't
i can't say one food it's like i love
that many food love pizzas burgers wings
thai food
chinese food let me ask you advice on
this i just dropped like 30 pounds yeah
and i'm having a hard time cutting 10
pounds how do you cut weight so fast for
a fight because the face bit is the
easiest way that's what it's like for me
not everyone says oh these [ __ ] i do
i go up to like
200 pounds last time i start seven weeks
out
so
seven weeks out the monday seven weeks
out i was eighty eight point eight kilo
last time
basically 89 that's like well
one nine six one nine seven something
along that lens
and
i was like five weeks later six weeks
like that i was like
78 points something i mean i lost like
10 kilo in like five weeks
and then
by fight week i get to like 75 70 76
and then i have to cut the five kilo
which is not
it's nothing to cut 10 11
how do you what do you do in the past
you've probably should have definitely
seen the video of me being sick in the
cage vomiting in the cage wow
i've not seen it about jesus because i
started their photos
that went five years ago i defended me
belts on cage already against juliana
rosa someone who you'll know
um
at the of me bells again it was a close
fight to be honest if it was the new
judging system now i probably would have
lost the fight because it was still the
old judging system i definitely won the
first three rounds with like controlling
but then i gassed bad because i've done
19 pound overnight
to make 145. 19 pounds overnight yeah
um it was like
yeah it's so funny that when i when i
asked uh on the mike tyson podcast or i
said something about uh how i asked
chuck liddell has anybody ever donated a
pint of blood to make weight and he says
that's a good idea
how much is a pint of blood 16 ounces is
a pint so that's that's a full [ __ ]
pound and then i was thinking last night
i wonder if you could uh take out the
blood and then just put it back in
that's blood dopamine though with it
everybody is it yeah that's what that's
class does blood open did you see what
happened to me boy paulo costa the other
day
dude [ __ ] knocked on his door at six
a.m or seven am before his weight while
he's awake and weighs some [ __ ] talk
blood
it's cheeky that looks
wow i'd be telling him
i mean he was weighing pretty heavy like
pretty close to his fight right here's
the thing i saw that he made weight
185.5 yeah which is like even like you
know
i mean it's totally illegal if it's not
a championship bout but he's uh
made weight but the thing was i saw him
on the scale he looked like unhealthy to
like
i don't think he looked up i don't think
he looked bad i mean i love [ __ ]
yeah i just don't think he's a natural
middleweight life have you ever
flogged if you found someone pictures
from my weight cuts years ago yeah
that's true too i looked head up a lot
like eyes drawn in my head but like i uh
jim and our team have let mistake
mistakes from our past known i mean me
and molly and a few of the older people
in the gym have done the bad weight cuts
to realize what we need to do so none of
the younger ones do that now yeah now
you look good on your on your way in no
nowadays it's easy others to say uh
i'm mentally strong enough to do [ __ ]
25 pounds if i need to
but
11 pounds or not
you're epic man so what i was going to
say is that i'm i'm a food addict too
right like i just got in real trouble
with sugar and and i i got like fatter
than i've ever been and then i finally
just buckled down and got in a food
program and i thought like i'd lost so
much weight i got like way skinnier but
my [ __ ] scale told me i'm still 179
pounds and i thought there's no [ __ ]
way my scale's wrong i have to buy a new
scale i gotta buy a new scale so then i
thought last night well [ __ ] we're gonna
be with patty tomorrow and my experience
with them at mike tyson's podcast was
just like he's not the kind of guy that
gets offended or sensitive like he just
doesn't give a [ __ ] and i was like i
want to buy a new scale anyway
so what if i buy a brand new scale on
the way to go meet patty and then see if
he wants to hop on it let's do it right
here i don't give a [ __ ] jesus i don't
give a [ __ ] i knew he wouldn't
well you want to film that this is our
way of going for a viral mma [ __ ]
media moment well hold on what do you
think you are right now i'm saying i
didn't eat
i didn't eat that much yesterday to be
honest
only i had a it was a [ __ ] big-ass
portion of the portions here just
ridiculous yeah it's a big ass horse
a pad side big ass porsche and a pad
thai and what the we had a few starters
and that as well but
i'll get on these now yeah you just just
need to stand on them yep
maybe empty your pockets
these these are a bit weighty these
shorts but they're not that weighty i
took my watch off what do you think you
are
i think we've got the attention of the
mixed martial arts community right now
and can i point out to the dedicated
listeners of the wild ride podcast
the different people we've had on who
are raving about their whoop band i mean
people from bert kreicher patty the
baddie like
it's insane
how
awesome the woot band is and how awesome
the people are who love it and i'm
telling you man like today
i know how many calories i burned while
skateboarding in halifax nova scotia
i also
know that
i i did some good work building aerobic
fitness and strength spent 25 minutes at
70 to 80 percent of my maximum heart
rate of course that's four four minutes
less than i typically spend while
skateboarding
dude what doesn't my whoop band tell me
this
tells me that
i could have recovered a little better
but what do you expect man i woke up in
newfoundland
i had to fly to
get to halifax
and
flew private the first time i ever paid
for
flying private so we flew on a 1976 prop
plane because that was the cheapest
and uh you know i just can't tell you
enough how much i love all the insight i
get from my woot band how my sleep is
you know i could have slept more last
night but
26.4 of the time was spent in rem sleep
that might indicate that my body is
making up for not getting enough rem
sleep recently dude it just goes on and
on the insights from my woot band it's
the most sophisticated fitness tracking
device known to man
all the coolest people use it and if you
go to woop.com that's w-h-o-o-p
dot com and use the promo code stevo not
only will you get 15 off at checkout on
your membership but you get the
waterproof whoop 4.0 band absolutely
free
come in come on the waterproof charger
slides right on so you never have to
take the band off i mean what's it gonna
take to get you to care about your
fitness to get you to finally jump on
the whoop train
i think this is it this is your calling
so go to woof.com use the promo code
stevo for 15 off at checkout now let's
see how much patty weighed
206.6 but he's got clothes on right
there
dude that's like really
cool i mean he was saying dude you're
gonna do that like okay you can't i was
going to get on a scale and i was like
you know i don't think
i actually i weighed myself before in 5
40. i was 202.
so
play out a bit heavy
well probably you got [ __ ] because
because like you know i've got clothes
on that these are the bit everyday
shorts but i haven't got nothing really
in me pockets like what i mean and then
but you just ate probably drink water
that counts oh yeah
i did i used to like try to like weigh
myself and then like
you
uh
you can't weigh yourself any other time
apart from first thing in the morning
yeah right especially if you're a
fighter anyway i mean we don't wear
ourselves apart from any other time
as
first thing in the morning but how do
you lose hi that can have i got on the
scales in the night
like if i had gone on the scales them
scales tonight after we've when the net
and [ __ ] what's the ufc 209 210 easy
yeah i mean yeah become pretty obsessive
with like wait i'm i get bloated lad
like i sit there when i get bloated
someone was meant
you said to me today
he was i don't know if it was game or
someone anyway manager or someone
when i like get a full belly and eat me
further they would just sit there and
let me belly pure bloats
i just sit there doing that like it
comes pure out loud i just sit there
doing that rubbing it and someone said
to me i don't know it was a game or
someone saying hey
when you when he sits there and gets
full he starts rubbing his belly like
it's an old friend he's missed
yeah
that's epic so uh is is darren till part
of your gym no no he stays in a
different gym right there's another gym
in there
there's a few gyms in the pill to be
honest the pills being like one of the
main mma gyms since day one is that leon
edwards is from birmingham yeah
liverpool's the birthplace of the
beatles yeah
i went to that beatles pub when i was
last time i was there
yeah
i was in there a couple of months ago
watching me friend friend in there jamie
yeah
it must be a crazy experience like
growing up there and then being able to
play there like [ __ ] i made it oh yeah
you mean it's
not but he's traveling everywhere now
jamie webster's name as loud as music's
unbelievable
nice so you got your own podcast yeah
let's promote it like
that's what i mean most americans don't
really understand that it's called chat
and pony with a particular body but
you just don't really know what pony
stands for do you just what is the
standpoint [ __ ] i care about
there's got to be a podcast called
talking [ __ ] with some you know yeah
definitely not i mean so just thoughts
but i always say i'll stop chatting pony
not all right people are just talking
[ __ ] i mean
i think that the problem probably goes a
little bit further than people being
able to understand the title of the
podcast oh yeah probably more that they
just can't understand [ __ ] that's set on
period a lot of people
a lot of people can't understand me well
i mean when i'm in america i have to
slow down
i'm doing a pretty good job of
understanding everything that you're
saying but you grew up in london so like
i grew up in england i did
remember at least more in england than
anywhere else
[Music]
yeah
um
well i was born in wimbledon uh i lived
near camden town yeah i went to um the
american school in london
there's an american school and it's like
a super privileged school
like it's like it's like like eighty
percent of my senior graduating class
went to ivy league schools like hives
and stuff yeah harvard and stuff 100 and
you were the 20 that i was a loser for
going to the university of miami
and i was a loser at the university
but yeah dude she's so crazy man and um
i was just truly impressed i brought up
darren till because
i was just like we were talking about
liverpool and i was i say uh on the mike
tyson pod because i'm like oh darren
till's been stepping out of line because
i saw something about he leaked ariel
helwani's cell number and like then
somebody else was bitching about
something about darren till and uh
patty's just like
nope
i'm bad that's what he said
[Music]
it was just so rad and and like and i
was like you know what i'm backing
darren to you
yeah it's from by oslo yeah i don't have
i don't have any uh
whoever else it was yeah i don't know i
don't have any particular crap wait you
know one thing about darren like where
he's like
like his whole mantra was like i i am
the best fighter in the planet you know
i'm the big you know and i just felt
like he kind of said that a lot
you know like
he got rushed on to me and he
should have took it a bit slower
that's what you were saying your plan is
yes
i'm not in no rush at all i loved your
uh reaction when i asked you what you
thought of sean o'malley and and uh
pyotr yan and he said it's win-win for
him yeah this it's a win-win thrall man
because no one
no one expects him to win no no no one
and it's someone in the division that
you know he's going to stand with him
for five rounds if it's a five-round
fight you know three
[Music]
if it was to be honest because you know
young can go far but do you mind you
want to do that with sean but he'll be
ready to go far like i'm ready to go
five everyone every fight to this
yeah
you have no fight on the schedule at the
moment is that right no no fight on the
schedule but i've got my eyes set on the
december 10 card
it's got me excited to be honest i've
been excited in a long time but if
you're shading
the octagon the same night as jon jones
you're gonna be excited later yeah dude
yeah john john sat in that same seat
while i was sitting in the seat uh john
jones for me he's the gold dude you
gotta give it to him i remember watching
that fight live when he got dq'd just
like whoa what's being doing for
with the elbow
eq that needs overtaking and just so
he's got i know on his record because he
he's the man john jones
he's uh he's a
definitely
complex individual yeah he is
that's what i mean that's another thing
like obviously
people don't say this and not about them
but bloody was out partying
sniffing a week before title defenses
and then just landed in the octagon and
finishing people yeah
that's a gangster right there
couldn't have said it better myself out
of all the people we've hung out with
like dude i had the best time hanging
out at john jones's house for the those
couple days like dude he's just so
accommodating he's like a little kid
he's bringing out drones and like dude
here put this on you're like flying a
drone like he he was i miss
my guy hanging out with jon jones yeah
i'm looking forward to like being on the
same cards and that's something that
does excite me being on the same car
this jones yeah do you know
who do you want to fight i don't give a
[ __ ] anybody said that like people ask
me you do you want to fight and sam i
don't mean to say any any name yeah it's
that simple i don't need to mention
anyone's life
because people talk about me
like people are just mentioning me left
writing centered and interviewed like
people who aren't my weight
talking about me to saying seeing some
[ __ ] saying oh i'll come up to
featherweight and fight him why would i
why would i go down to featherweight to
fight some no one know what i mean yeah
unbelievable and i think
i don't know that i've ever heard a
fighter say like
at a public level
i don't care who i fight i just don't
want to fight a ranked opponent
like that you know there's no point yeah
i'm not in no rush yeah as i say there's
no point in
jumping out of me like hey i'm going to
fight him i'm going to fight him
lightweight it doesn't work like that
right other divisions you can't do it
lad because other divisions aren't shark
tanks
but this division is a crazy shark tank
club as they were saying through the day
it should have the top 30
have a lot of the top 15. but the
divisions can just about eat out the top
15 and 15 to 10. snad
but
the top 15 of my waiters
top
top notch fighters
yeah
yeah instead shark tank is a good way to
put it um you know you say you spent a
lot of time in san diego yeah this is
like me second loan this is me home from
home and i'm went away from liverpool
especially if i'm in the states i'm
generally in
my name in san diego a whales vagina
yeah
yeah i went to wales for jacksonville
that's on the uncommon increment okay
never seen come on i have i
[Music]
no it's not
no it's not
yeah i love it i'm so uh two second home
so how much time out of the year are you
going to be here
well like i came out for the first time
last year and
after me first right after my debut came
i got in like halloween i was here to
like the end of november
and then i came out in the start of
april and went home and like
mid-may and then again i came on
okay i got to san diego about two weeks
ago or something and
i'm here for another two weeks something
like that all right it's definitely a
fun place to be oh it's quality we
always get the weather like that's yeah
so on the
there's only love in the uk a lot just
getting the weather like this it's like
this all year long that's what i mean
it's like that i've been here when it's
like it rained but
back home i wouldn't call it rain
but everyone here was like it's raining
draining i'm like
this isn't rain what are you talking
about rain this isn't rain and they're
like oh it's raining like people like
i'm just gonna wait till the rain goes
off and not that i have you like
we drive in torrential storms back home
get out there and get in your car
sure that's mad well i'd love to live in
i'd love to live in like conditions like
this
yeah can you see yourself moving here
i don't know maybe after the retire the
sun but yeah
i've got me
my family my gme team back home knowing
me name
obviously my fiance's we've talked about
our mums and dads and
i've got nieces and nephews so she know
obviously so
yeah dude i'd want to move my whole
family over here they came over but at
the same time i want my kids to be
proper mickey's i'd want my kids to be
scousers
mickey's scouters i don't know
that question too
i want my kids to be scousers love all
right did you uh see that michael
bisping documentary yeah no
you say that i watched it
on the way here on the flight yeah dude
i [ __ ] we flew to hawaii
a couple months ago and i watched it on
the fly i watched it on the way from
chicago i was like dude thank you for
making that flight it's so
enjoyable it was funnier because me the
missus was asleep and she she like
walked up like half an hour fortunately
and got the got one of my earphones off
me
and started watching and then like
about half an hour ago she went
is he got one eye yeah i went whoa it's
like are you messing you know what i
mean how did you not know baseball had
one eye like this well documents oh i
didn't know we had him on the podcast he
took out his eye for us
so we need i told her to watch like the
stars of documentary when we landed she
texted them oh my what's the bismuth
documentary did you know we had one line
she was like yeah i knew we had one like
and this is we paid mum yeah i mean it
was like
like
50 something i did speaking of which
scott's brother is like not even
remotely a ufc fan and
i told him that we had you on the
podcast today and he was like [ __ ] yeah
dude
i was like you watch ufc's like no dude
the guy's all over social media
i mean you're bigger than [ __ ] mma
like it's it's like you you uh what do
you call it transcend the [ __ ] mma
you say that that's what i've always
said i was gonna do what i mean and i'm
gonna continue to do it i've i know i am
not i've seen this in my future for
years
that i always said i'm gonna be in the
ufc
like even before like i started fighting
mma
i don't i might even said it before it's
trained was like a number and i used to
be a proper little [ __ ] i remember doing
these videos on youtube ufc prediction
videos okay before i ever started mma i
was just putting them on youtube i
remember i started speaking to a fellow
through it
and he messaged me like a year ago
and i got out of the blue it was a fella
that we spoke to like 12 years ago
messaged me out of the blue saying or
they could actually see it in the fc
after saying for all them years you were
going to be know what i mean it's just
someone that i spoke to on youtube and i
was like 14.
it was mad
yeah as well yeah my my brother was like
all stoked he text me a couple questions
asked and he was like dude you gotta ask
him who's bigger [ __ ] english or
americans
i don't know
probably probably both [ __ ] in
different kind of ways to be honest it's
kind of saying like who's bigger
[ __ ] like there's yes there's
different types of
[ __ ] there's all different types of
[ __ ]
like people are going to be [ __ ]
everywhere yeah
like
there's nowhere that's not going to
happen
but i feel like in england like you like
you grew like did you grow up fighting
like i mean in grade school in high
school a little bit later i mean i had a
few fights in first year senior school
when i was like 11. but it's it's like
it's not like the movie like soccer
hoola again where i'm you guys are just
everyone always asks me about that you
know but
that doesn't happen no more
that used to happen in the eights bad in
the 70s 80s 90s and then i think
england's like the most cctv country in
the world love hey like square square
mile i think liverpool could be one of
the highest per square mile cctv
in this city in the whale but the amount
of cctv in the uk is ridiculous yeah and
then they brought mandatory sentences in
so if you're fighting at a football
match so like if you get caught fighting
on the street with someone you might get
a six-month sentence tops know what i
mean it's not like you're like walking
around flip-flops like they're all
they're there yeah you're just walking
in mobs if you get caught fighting at a
football match you get a five-year
sentence mandatory
really yeah yeah that did get a little
bit out of the end
what's so funny man when i was uh
attending my little [ __ ] rich kids
school in [ __ ] uh st john's wood the
american school in london like literally
a [ __ ] block or two
down the road from there was like a
properly hard [ __ ] scary british
public school called quentin kiniston
and they used to beat us up all the time
like it was so [ __ ] dude don't go
near there there was like
oh it's a qk oh no
you know and we get mugged all the time
too like uh you got mugged i did get my
dollar time and it was so crazy all the
time
it didn't happen all the time but i got
mugged
at least
three times properly and by properly i
mean knife pointer i got a knife in my
pocket give me kissy watch you heard
something like that like that that
happened like but it was either i have a
knife or like
give me that skateboard or i'm gonna
[ __ ]
beat you up right now and you just gave
him the skateboard
americans might be a little bit bigger
[ __ ] dude took my skateboard and then
made me buy a bag from him
are you serious yeah now give me all
your money you can have your board back
how much
oh my god dude that's heavy [ __ ] thought
like how old is it
yeah he's like 23.
yeah i was like
i'm thinking i was like 13 maybe 14. i
feel like you've never told that story
before i've never told i've never
admitted that to another living soul
that's heavy
it's rough though certain parts of
london can be very rough yeah and
especially because we would go around
skateboarding and like our like the
skate spots are not necessarily in nice
parts but we will just love
skateboarding we want to go ride that
and so that puts us where the [ __ ]
guys are
that's that that hat's cool i'll take it
yeah
yeah my favorite hat i'm one of them one
time i got mugged
what time i mean that's like a
life-changing event it's happened like
seven times
but the stakes are like kind of lower
like they don't have like the guns now
they're starting to have guns in england
oh yeah there's
people someone got shot the other week
by ours oh i mean it's there's more guns
now with it
it's knives that's the problem in the uk
you know what i mean there was a
an 11 year old girl sort of got stabbed
in the neck and said the city center
last year
was he being an issue a lot it's just
some of the stuff you hear about there's
people getting stabbed left right in
centre london
wish for it you did a lot a lot about it
in london and birmingham people getting
stabbed
but obviously it's not as it's not as
bad as guns yeah you've got to be this
close to someone that actually stopped
them holding me in right just stands
from six miles away with a sniper head
and shoot them on the earth
america with the [ __ ] guns man them
are 15
stay away from me
not it's not red um is that peaky
blinders that was a liverpool no that's
beaming them
it's based in beam it's
set in beam again but the film in
liverpool because the ducks and stuff
okay did you see the latest season uh i
haven't seen it i haven't finished it
yet but i'm like savoring it you know
like i only like break off a little
chunk at a time because i know
like that
this is good but i think americans love
it more than yeah of course okay oh yeah
[ __ ] i did that i'm busted out i will
admit my favorite ones like the wire the
sopranos game of thrones
game of thrones but i couldn't get into
the wires surprised the wire is
good the wire got voted like
the best number one top ten
series of all time
another good one that i like called love
hate
it's hard
to know how to share these like five
series of it's [ __ ] cool it's like a
hopeless romantic flick a lot it's
what's it called love hate i'm down for
that that's sick it's got a little
finger then after game of thrones okay
he's one of the uh
okay the gangsters in it yeah
like i don't know i watched it on like
dvd
i don't know what i mean yeah that's
right it's probably somewhere tell us
about molly dude because like you guys
are just such the raddest duo and that
you know like yeah she's great she's an
author i really get a kick out of you
guys together yeah
you know like for the last half you know
all three of your fights
we fought on the same card so next one's
going to be a little bit different says
we're going to be on different kinds
she's in madison square she's an msg and
i want to be like a month later i just i
just feel like maybe maybe i'm tripping
but i feel like
molly was in the ufc
before you and kind of under the radar
like not really and then once you came
in you elevated her
where it's like
just this [ __ ] phenomenon of you guys
together and and she's just become such
a more like charismatic
seemingly she's shining she's shining so
much yes she is like has
something we've said before like she's
done all that hard work in the ufc no i
mean where she had six before i got
tired she had six fights one three lost
three know what i mean like she got
sandwiched she was like six or seven and
one what i mean so
she had to do it laying on the job she
only thinks she only i like three how
much her fights as well know what i mean
yeah she had to do early in on the job
in the ufc that way she had to do what
on the job laying in on the job learning
on the job
outside the ufc and
i'm so happy that they happened back
then now because i wouldn't be coping
with everything now as good as i do
i don't want to be saying anything
disparaging about molly before you got
to the ufc but there's just been this oh
yeah i don't know everyone said it to us
she said that herself like she always
said it like she had a one of our next
teammates was on cards with her in the
past
and she just like he i had ever saying
it to me in the apex
like she said to me fight week as well
like the day before the weigh-in when
we're sitting there watching
food challenges just sitting there both
starving watching food challenge just
like oh it's just she's just like just
different when it's with you pad and the
shame again when we was in the apex
before we went to walk out she was like
i know i know we're gonna go out there
and kill it i know we are i was like i
just know because it's me and you
and
ever since then we've both been just
going out there and killing her she's
just
evidently you both are just having so
much fun yeah we are yeah and it's it's
it's infectious man it's like it's like
it just it
it's like [ __ ] contagious joy and and
i just want to see you guys keep killing
it i love what she said too that she's
uh she's not ready for valentina
shevchenko but she's ready for the
sister yeah
that was a pretty hilarious call out
yeah
like i'll get i'll be i'll be ready for
valentina but right now just
dance it's great you brought you touched
on the surface of mental health and you
had issues outside the ring and you're
glad you cured them and and i think a
lot of people listening have those same
issues but like nobody gets help
correction scott all kinds of people get
help and thankfully plenty more can get
help now because this episode is brought
to you by better help which is an online
therapy service that allows you to link
up with qualified therapists to get you
the help that you need and i could not
be more thrilled to be in therapy i
think i talk about it at length in this
episode with patty the baddie and i
encourage you guys to try it out too
because i mean you you maintain your car
right you want to maintain your body why
wouldn't you want to maintain your mind
because i mean like patty says dude like
he'd rather go
to he'd rather have his his mate crying
on his shoulder than go to his mate's
funeral next week
man it's powerful stuff and
guys need to speak up like patty says
and the best way to speak up is with a
qualified therapist which you can find
at betterhelp.com
that's better
h-e-l-p-com
and if you go to betterhelp.com stevo
you get 10 off your first month so it's
a win-win for the listeners of the wild
ride podcast and man i really genuinely
hope that you guys jump on this deal so
that you can speak up about what's
bothering you because man it just makes
you happier it makes me happier man i'm
doing therapy every single week and i
love it so one more time go to
betterhelp.com
stevo to try out this therapy and 10 off
your first month yeah dude now let's get
back to it
how did you like solve those problems
before because i'm in the same situation
too and like i'm i'm diving deep and
like
you know yesterday on the drive down
here i had a panic attack and uh it's
just like i called my therapist and
she's like dude you you're like so
[ __ ] exposed to the roots that like
things are starting to come up and so
like you know just how did you
how did you kind of like
fix those and like because you knew
you're going to become famous yeah and
so it's like
you got to kind of put the cage around
the you
know when i was when i was younger
like
it's mad because like even when i was an
amateur i caused a big ruckus
i mean when i was an amateur when i was
16 i put a post on cage audios for
that cage what he was big show in the uk
in the order
and the other four of them on there like
the sheer dog one what i mean years ago
and i put a post on the amateur forum
when i was like
four or no five no amateur saying i am
the best amateur bantamweight in the
country does anyone dispute this
so people were putting names on this
list i was just beating them so from
that young age at like 16 when i put
that up i've started getting used to
like getting abuse you know what i mean
because like people are like oh these
[ __ ] this that blah blah i like this is
eve like facebook was going on so like
obviously it went on today and like i
got it i built a bit of a reputation
when i was an amateur i went no no
name and then i went pro
with friend oprah and then got santa
cage where he is like i went out when i
was 17 because he had no one left to
fight so it was two and a white time at
him eighteen one another fights got
sounds cage audios
and then i was getting built up then
there's like a big thing about me first
cage where he's fighting then i lost me
next fight
obviously me ed was a bit shocked at
them but it was only a kid so it was
like oh it's sad i mean i'm only 18.
went on a [ __ ] fight winston clad won
the cage audios featherweight belt
and he
started having to do proper crazy weight
cuts
145's killing me and i lose a close
fight for the belt
after that fight me i've didn't fight
for like 10 months i was
like
i i soul can flip when i lose a game of
cards
i mean so come on always and i've not
prepared i've not prepared for not put
hours and hours of practice into
but when i come whenever i like losing a
fight affects me in a big way you know
what i mean like
so you're saying you won the belt and i
want the bells of featherweights and
then ended up losing it and that's when
i didn't know that i didn't play for ten
months then but like i didn't get down
as bad as it did after the next one i
mean i was down
i can remember
crying a lot then i'm an emotional guy
like i cry i cry commercials on the
telly okay yeah i swear
after the like i lost the featherweight
belt it was like oh down on the dumpster
end of moving up to
moving up to lightweight
i won by flying triangle i was like oh
yeah everything's back everything's back
on you know it's back to normal
everything's back to the way it was
no need to worry anymore
and then we next fight that well i broke
my hand in the lead up to that fight i
broke me for you bone and the lead up to
the sevedos fight fought went to america
for four weeks train come back can
you've got a broken bow in your hand and
they made me get surgery before me fight
so we had surgery 12 weeks before the 4
for the lightweight belt
and i got the wires to help me on six
weeks before the fight the fight and
then forget it i'm taking the wires out
man i'm sitting there going yeah i'm
fighting in six weeks and the oldest
runs
you know it's like i mean i've been
saying them for and they're like no you
know i was like wow no i am he brought
that just doesn't add up to me 12 weeks
and then you got your wires taken out
the the hardware is supposed to be in
there for a minimum of an entire year
before it comes out right like you know
with this one it was just like wire like
little wires were in there and they just
like pulled the wires out so they're
keeping them maybe that's different than
hardware that's screwed into bed yeah no
and then the next time i had like i had
like bolts the next time and that was
like that one again now in the uk was
only like eight weeks
but [ __ ] went into that fight nearly
choked them out in the first round but
because my arm was that weak i didn't i
couldn't get the squeeze on the
reenacted joke no because it just didn't
have to stand the other hand did
[ __ ]
the squeeze couldn't get it next night
they hit him broke me and ended up
losing a close decision
and then after that fight that because
like even though i had the broken hand
ladder put everything into the build up
to it what i mean i'd say my ass off and
nothing
i just remember we went back to like the
apartment we were staying and swimming
we made to a party you know what i mean
where he'd been up anyway [ __ ] and i
just went to bed i'm just sitting there
crying
and then most i think
nearly every morning for the next six
weeks or something i woke up crying
because the missus would go to work
and when she goes away i had just
normally i'd roll over and just go
asleep knowing me but after that fight
that just
i'd wake up on it just like be like wow
yeah you lost that fight
your kitty is over you're finished and i
just start crying
but you but you fixed it yeah they are
too don't be like
for a few months that was bad love for a
few months but how did you fix it i
don't know that you fix it i think that
the like but you had better coping
skills
i didn't tell anyone
i thought oh no i'm like
all the macho [ __ ] i'm a fighter i
shouldn't have to go to my fiance or my
mom or dad all my friends or my
teammates i shouldn't have to put this
bed on them no i mean so you talk to
somebody about it so yeah for about two
months i was bad i was just crying all
the time and just never in a good mood
and that's just not me you know what i
mean i'm not like that i'm always even
when i'm on a good mood i've generally
got a smile on me face
on when's the last time you lost your
fight
thoughtfully
okay so we're not necessarily out of the
woods no we're not right
but as you say it was it was actually
speaking to people
because
someone's i seen someone or someone said
to me get it off your chest that helps
i think you're gonna be boxing coaches
actually right like he was the first
person we spoke to about and then i
started speaking to other people and it
was it was weird it's literally like
someone does
pull a [ __ ] 50 key they'll wait off
your chest we're only as sick as our
secrets yeah let's leave they keep the
track
yeah drag you down but yeah
for sure speaking up about stuff that
bothers you
saves my ass yeah all the time
definitely yeah you don't have to tell
you know everybody everything but you
should tell us
the ones that you know love you and you
love them because that's what i mean
when i when i did win that belt when i
was 21 and i had maybe definitely had
this in the past major clean guns people
you think are friends just with you
should we call them clean guns soon i
mean just hanging off your coattails
just widget to get into nightclubs and
to yeah be part of these mates you know
what i mean [ __ ] like that
and at the time when you're with them
your actual mates and your fiance like
what are you doing i need me teammates
in the gym like what are you doing with
them show your [ __ ] something like how
they sound like i don't know what i mean
in the sound
and then if a year passes or whatever
passes and you're like
what else they were right-wing they were
just when you lose a fight and then
you're not getting messages or
you've lent someone money or you [ __ ]
don't know and they just don't want to
get back on yeah i'm just like yeah it's
sad you realize who the real ones are
and that's why i'm so happy that
happened when i was 21 when i was
younger when i won the world title on
cage
because back then i got the opportunity
when i won the belt i could just went
straight to the ufc and i would have had
all them clings on by klingons by me sad
but i'm glad i never went to ufc and
i've offended the belt and then lost it
after the defender
because i wouldn't have had all the life
lessons i've got now yeah dude that's
fantastic
do you still have a better
we were still working with better help
right
yeah that's uh yeah we
did therapy is crucial
um
so i mean there's just no funding for
that i know there's none in the uk and
i'm it would be surprising if there was
any ford in the us you know what i mean
like men's mental health there's no
funding for in the uk at all there's no
phone number
funding oh yeah there's no funding at
all like no let's remember too
that patty
was it the last fight jordan levitt yeah
yeah and he says i'm going to submit him
and then i'm going to teabag him
did you call that out ahead of time yeah
i said i was gonna knock him out so
submit him and then t-bag and just said
that i'm gonna finish him
yeah and i knew i was gonna finish him i
did think more chance of it being a
knockout because he was a better he had
good jiu-jitsu
he was yeah he's a legit black belt
yeah black belt but
his striking defense was so weird
striking defense is just like that until
he grabs older and it was my own fault
as i said i went into the fight very
emotional was very overzealous i was
trying to take his head off with every
puncher through so because i was trying
to take his head off it was easier for
him to just pull me in and get that bald
of me
and that was the same fight where five
hours before your weigh-in you received
the news that you're afraid you've lost
you you told
he was from
submitting jordan levitt to tea bagging
him just like he said and [ __ ]
dancing or giving like the most stellar
post fight interview
and then just politely asking um
do you mind if i have a few words not
like grabbing the microphone like a
douche like i would
you know but like two hands yeah do you
mind do you mind if i have a few words
and they just of course and then he just
goes into this like wonderful moving
speech about how
we have to remove the stigma of guys not
being able to talk he says i'd rather
uh my mate cry on my shoulder then be at
his funeral the next week like we've got
to start talking and it was just the
most [ __ ] genuine authentic just
moving this beautiful [ __ ] that you
couldn't like be trying to like put on
to look good
what kind of where do you want to see
the money go for the funding for mental
health like what what needs to be
well i'll be honest i'm no expert a lot
of that i just know that people need
help because
even in liverpool a lot of liver
liverpool fit into san diego like eight
and a half times
and i know
like more than one ten people who are
not
not that i know directly or know of have
killed themselves over like the past 10
years yeah
like it's just becoming more and more
common like it's normal and it's not
yeah it's not normal that people need to
realize that like split second decisions
right change lives
yeah don't expect a split second
decision more unlike things that i've
seen of people who have attempted
suicide and have
failed you've always said as soon as you
start to do it i was thinking to myself
what the [ __ ] are you doing
i've expected it instantly well what's
crazy is like most people have these
secrets that they think is the worst
thing that's ever happened in their life
and then when you finally tell somebody
they're like i do that all the time
exactly
what do you what yeah i did that three
times last week yeah
you know it's part of the 12 steps that
you do a fear inventory
and that's where like
you know well not even a fear inventory
but like all the harms you've done to
others
right but there's there's harmed on
others there's uh
you know resentments that you have and
there's a fear inventory and so like on
your fear inventory you you have to
write down like
you know everything that you're afraid
of of course but the thing is i remember
when i was going through the process i
was thinking of like some secrets that i
had and i was like man i don't have to
share this with anybody it's not like
anything that i'm resentful about it's
not going to make me angry you know it's
not like
you know it's not anything i'm really
like afraid of it's just like some weird
[ __ ] i do you know
but then i but then my next thought was
oh [ __ ] it's some weird [ __ ] i do
that
i would [ __ ] never tell anyone
because i'm i'd be terrified of anybody
finding it out yeah and then that's when
i realized that by definition
a secret is something you're afraid
someone will find out yeah so in this
process you have to share all of your
secrets and that's when the rubber meets
the road in the 12-step process of
recovery and what i did with my secrets
at that point i [ __ ]
went to my notebook and i wrote them in
code because heaven [ __ ] forbid if
anybody got their hands on my notebook
and then they could read my [ __ ]
secrets so i wrote them in code that
only i would understand and then i told
my guy who i had to tell it to
i just made an appointment and
i when when the time came i showed up
and i was like uh all right dude you
know [ __ ] that
it's like it's a big [ __ ] deal it's a
big deal it's like it's like uh what the
bull fighting guy said my guy my buddy
ty the bull fighter he says uh you're
never ready to ride the ball it just
becomes your turn yeah
and that's what it was
you know i was never going to be ready
to share those secrets but
it became time you know i scheduled the
appointment so i go and i was like all
right here goes and then now the guy who
i'm sharing this with my you know i'll
just go ahead and say my my sponsor like
he had told me he goes look he had eight
years of sobriety at the time he had
told me he goes dude look
you can tell me anything trust me i've
been doing this for years i've heard it
all you're not gonna tell me anything
that i haven't [ __ ] heard before so
just don't even worry about it just let
it rot so i show up with my [ __ ]
coded secrets right i sit down and i'm
not gonna tell him
and he sits there
listens to me when someone wants to know
what i say and he literally goes
ding ding ding that i have not heard
and we just started [ __ ] laughing and
this [ __ ] that this
this [ __ ] that like was like so
terrifying to me that
and when i wrote it in code at the top
of the page i had written to the grave
like this was my to the grave list
yeah i wrote the words to the grave dude
and uh and here when i told my sponsor
we just started [ __ ] laughing about
how ridiculous it was and like i felt
like wow you know like
like i i had so much invested in that
festering [ __ ] fear and it was just
kind of released for sure it was
released and it was the most powerful
thing you get a lot of guys you work
with that like can't stay sober and then
like you know you go through things and
then you go to the steps and you work it
and then they relapse and you're like
would you would you not tell me yeah
all right i hooked up with the dude when
i was 12 you know it's like
and it's like who cares and then like
from then on they they they
yeah
we have a book for our whole process
that which is that it's actually we call
it the big book and uh in the book it
says if you don't if you hold back a
secret if you don't share everything you
will drink again yeah it says you'll
drink it like just black and white like
that and um when i got done with this
process with with the sponsor guy i
finally came to i said okay now i
finally don't have any anything else and
he says all right
you are the first guy i've ever worked
with in this process who i am not now
asking
so
what are you holding back
he says i i know that you have not held
back anything i know and he says he says
are you curious to know and i'm like
what he and he said
60.
i'm like six year old he goes 60 hours
we put into this process really
it was the gnarliest marathon fifth step
that and i think he did a lot of
rounding up but yeah i [ __ ] and then
and and that's why i think i'm still
clean and sober today because uh i like
like that's when you when you've shared
your all of your secrets when you've
just like gotten it all out that's when
um
like you're no longer on defense
you know like in the steps now like you
like the the obsession to drink and use
is lifted and you're not no longer in
defense you move into the the rest of
the steps where you actually
make all the things right from your past
and now you're on offense yeah and and
like offense meaning that when you go
through the the second half of the steps
you're on [ __ ] offense now you're
playing now you're winning now your
life's getting good and dude i'm
terrified to like not to deviate from
this process
because my life is so goddamn good nice
stuff
all right well do we can we do
predictions for tonight's fight and then
by the time this airs we can see if
they're true or not
i like that yeah let's do it yeah i mean
i i i like luke rock called
i you know i think i loved it i was
worried about this yeah i felt like i
snobbed me the other day a lot
you know what though i don't think that
that was to you i don't think i think
that he was just now at this point
though this is when i was walking to the
toilet
yeah i was walking to the toilet and i
think he'd just been back to see cheeto
because there's a teammate in it yeah
and he was coming back and i think i was
walking out obviously as you say people
were shouting me so i was touching hands
and he's like walk back through him yeah
i've like jogged past me but he asked
just like once
i was thinking he must be thinking yeah
he is this little [ __ ] because he
everyone's cheering his name and i'm a
former middleweight champ and why's no
one shouting for me no i mean he
probably thought that because if i was
in issues i'd probably think the same it
was this cheeky little bastard i think
that there there's probably some merit
to that assessment however
i think that he was just a walking snarl
yeah he was he was nice when the cameras
were on him he was just like you know i
think he would like it
to places like that on a vest
you can't hang up to places like that on
a vest yeah because you stink a bow
okay
now help me with that lingo in a vest do
you mean like wearing a bulletproof vest
no we had a vest on what do you call it
what is it a tank top do you call it
no sleeves so i
wow i did not know that
um i i think paolo me boy yes paulo i
think carlos got it paulo's gonna clip
his ass and put him i think paulo is
is uh coming in with a lot to [ __ ]
prove do you think he's drinking right
now before the fight
yeah you know what about the main one
dude i'll do it do you all do you know
what they say that when you hit your
prime
and [ __ ]
like then you're done
and aldo is legitimately having a second
there he is he's come back with a
vengeance
i can i hope he wins the bell to be sick
to see all over the bell because i'll
that was like
are those up there for me and like the
the goat starters stone the meanies up
there sure i don't give a [ __ ] of these
last loads of fight club sure i don't
care if he's lost a good few fights he's
unbelievable can we transfer that i
don't care if all those lost fights say
to yourself
that was the boy lad i just still can't
believe mcgregor done that to him you
just said that he was gonna do and done
it but
like it's just the fact that i'll do it
what the [ __ ] is going on with mcgregor
being so like uh
chest any
that's not natural it's testosterone trt
i mean why would he even want to be that
bloated up and and i want to be that big
dude i would love to be that [ __ ]
wait
if mcgregor stood on this stale at scale
right now what do you think he'd like to
always look and chest he likes to
probably be about the same as that
probably be heavier than me
220 a lot heavier than you is what i
would guess how tall is he you know he's
a little bit little and smaller than me
i think
i'm like five ten and a half nip
something like that i think he's 220
something like that probably because
he's he's like
[ __ ] jacked easy let's fight back his
face fight backward on the bm170 but he
could be getting jacked to this film
he's
doing couldn't he just doing a film
though yeah he's just [ __ ] enjoying
life on his lambo
i wonder what he's like you know my girl
my fiance lux she worked with mcgregor
on uh she works in production yeah as
like a set designer like art director
like a prop stylist all that
and
she said that that conor mcgregor of all
the celebrities she's worked with on a
set was among
the like like the top of the list for
the most uh like professional like like
uh
friendly like kind like the whole thing
and i gotta wonder just by looking at
him
in the news and the whole trajectory of
his story if that's still the case
well i was funny enough you mentioned i
was in dublin two or three weeks ago in
his pub
eating me and molly but in there i don't
know i'm gonna drink in a meal and he
he was on facebook
that's didn't he do anything about us he
was on facebook as he was talking to me
i think he did say something about me
speech and i was like thank you and he
said something else about me wimbo i
couldn't hear exactly what he was saying
because we were in a pub and the music
was loud no i mean so i wish there was a
pair of earphones to put in
but he sorted the bill for this lad so
oh wow
connor's a sculptor
it's a possibility that comes right down
to 155 that's a idea to be the biggest
pay-per-view in the history of the ufc
dude make it happen i mean they think
you can't put two stars that big
together that's not good for business
that's not good it's the best for
business dude i mean it's the best well
they're in the making money business
understood but this is why chael sonnen
just said that you cannot have
uh their what what fight was it it's
saying um
a champion from one division and a
champion from another division like he
was like you can't do that because then
you've just only made one go down
you know like isn't that what's going on
with jones and naganu
that would be a uh a unif well that'll
end up being unification fighting right
yeah is obviously if it's going to be
steve jones and everyone's saying steve
honest for the incident belt while and
gone who's out yeah and then
it'll be like whoever wins there isn't
ghana who's who wins jones naganu i'm
just backing jones against anyone for
sure i love it man i'm back against
anyone
you'll find a way to win i've got to get
my relationship back with jon jones man
i don't even know what happened here we
were bros we would [ __ ] hang out at
his house i missed jon jones and then
and then all of a sudden
then all of a sudden is just he never
responded to another message and i i
can't even [ __ ] guess like what you
did
but uh you loved it yeah everyone wants
to know you know i know i am
and i love your uh unconditional love
and support for john johnson
i'm dying for him to be the heavyweight
champion yeah when i first started
watching him he was like coming up you
know what i mean i i watched him
live
beat shogun and i remember the fight
before you'd be bated on vases and he
got offered the fight after the fight
and he said yeah i watched all them live
ma when he'd be
veda only remember watching all them
fights live the matt hamill one on the
ultimate fighter finale
because it was when i was younger i went
up that it just resonates even more with
me because like that was before i was
watching and watching them fight before
i was even doing mma and let's put this
into perspective you're in england which
is
[ __ ]
like nine hours ahead of las vegas time
so for you to watch those fights live
you're staying up until goddamn five six
in the morning
till like
if that's what i mean those main events
come out at like nine o'clock in vegas
10 o'clock don't do that so you're
sitting there waiting until about five
in the morning sometimes five five
seconds
i mean i don't watch ufc anymore right i
don't because i'm not sitting up and
ruining my sleeping pattern you know
what i mean i get up and sit up for
hours and hours on the monday when i go
in the gym i'm like oh but you won't go
on fight pass when you wake up yeah i'll
watch you like i always you'd always end
up just pulling your phone out and
seeing the results on instagram though
yeah i'm such a [ __ ] psycho like when
i'm when i'm on tour and i have a show
which requires me to be on stage during
the event yeah i will literally
[ __ ] rearrange the apps on my iphone
to move instagram away so that i don't
inadvertently open it oh yeah
i'm like
i just opened it like a natural reaction
of the morning
oh my god where is the feeling when you
when you open instagram and you're like
no why did i see that
that was really [ __ ] interesting man
for that one for me that's
just bad fight thank you he was
three minutes away from becoming every
champion of the world if he just stayed
on top
but he went for the leg lock instead
yeah dude
and let me let me play he's only young
in his kitty you're not like i've had
like double the amount of height to him
yeah yeah he got in late yeah and dude
now they got a fight night in paris and
it's cyril gone
i think
i think i love to eat two of us i love
his quality but i think he's gonna piece
him up
it was looking pretty scary for chewie
like uh he came in hot and then he lost
like three in a row and it was like man
[ __ ] poor bastard and now he's won three
in a row is that right he thinks more
like five in a row or something wow
are you good at the speed bag in the
boxing gym no no i [ __ ] hate that
thing dude i'm probably the best in the
world
i just like talking [ __ ] i'm pretty good
though i hate the [ __ ] annoying
you don't need that or not on either
it's just shoulder strength that was
pointless
let me let me ask you what what we're
getting into tonight and thank you so
much for uh for the invite dude what a
[ __ ] honor to go get to watch the
fights with paddy
that's my own allowance
but we have like a group chat by
ourselves 15 20 of us in it yeah and
it's funny he makes long held he's a pro
professional footy player for you soccer
player and ladder and i told him i was
coming on this he was like
lad probably made up east like after the
ufc i woke up the next morning to a
picture and i chatted me and you where
you'd put it up along he was like why
did you meet her what do you like what's
he like
sorry he loves you and ponzi has lots
there's been like there's been like some
really really special times where like
there's this mutual you know like like
we're jazzed up
like [ __ ] watching
watching you do much [ __ ] you know
we've had really great guests on this
podcast like make no mistake and i'm
super grateful and proud of uh of what
you know the way that that has gone for
us but
with that said like i look at other
podcasts like uh like the full send
podcast logan paul like andrew schultz
and they just said like they're [ __ ]
like just the crazy like
unbelievable caliber of guests and and i
see here looking at you thinking like
like uh man [ __ ]
beat logan paul
just like a full cent you know i i
really feel that you are that special
and just i love i love the ufc so god
damn much it's ridiculous no lots of
years of seeing you sitting at the side
of the ufc
i should have always saw this come on
one day because as i say i've been i've
envisioned all this i've imagined it for
years and years knowing i mean i've
always like when i first started doing
mma and i said i'm going to start doing
tournaments and fighting everyone said
you won't when i first started fighting
on my chairs i was going to win a belt
and i was like you won't i mean then it
was like i'm on a team but i was like
you won't i mean i was like i'm going to
win a world title you won't i don't want
it yeah i mean so
my life's been full of that love and
i've always beat it and i'm going to
continue to do so yeah and and so
i would like we'll wrap it up and get
out of here but but i'm i'm curious to
know like
about the business of patty the baddie
because there's there's uh you know and
we will talk about that everyone talked
about fight or pay all the time and like
they were trying to hit like uh ask you
if like they like it as if it was an
outrage that that you had 12 and 12 in
march like that's
that's just standard though right your
first ufc contract is 10 and 10 when
that 12 and 12 when that 14 and 14 but
i didn't have to have the 14 and 14
because you know the boys know what i
mean i got a new contract with me last
fight right
like obviously you know who the boy is
yeah
obviously fighting in the apex the way
even though there was only about 100
people there it was still quite loud
when i was fighting but then
you see it with a crowd like when i
fight with a car that's just different
that
and mind you when you walked in and just
because you were standing in the
building the entire [ __ ] arena starts
chanting oh patty the baddie while
there's [ __ ] legitimate activity
going on in the octagon they're trying
to [ __ ] announce the official results
and like nobody gives a [ __ ] about that
because patty's standing in the corner
of the arena over there it was so
ridiculous and i run over to take a
photo with you and then i come back to
my seat and i'm like yo dana dude
[ __ ] check it out and i sure didn't
know the picture of me and you and dana
said you know i'm like dude and dana's
like [ __ ] he's it's crazy like yeah
it's just rad it's not it's mad but like
as i said that like it's more crazy for
the people that are army like me mates
snowing at me and me makes me fiance
my fiancee's head's gone after time me
teammates and like me family and then
it's mad for them but
odd
people keep asking me are we a coupon
without this i'm like
i'mma cope with walking i mean you've
had this
this is it's not overnight no it's not
overnight
i'm saying i'm not doing this for nearly
12 years
for 11 years being fighting like felt 10
years now being fighting professional
saying to myself i know where i'm at i
know this is happening i know this is
happening
only about twice as i say when i've had
proper bad mental mental issues have i
ever thought it's not going to happen
every other time in my life i have been
like this is happening it's gone up and
i know what's gonna happen i've kind of
been the same way too like i'm like the
world's gonna find out how [ __ ] rad i
am it was my mind i always knew yeah i
always knew that like it's mad because
you could probably go back to the
interviews where they've done years ago
and stuff like that and they say
i am going to be just as big if not
bigger than conor mcgregor yeah i love
it i am to be fair i thought that the
world was likely to find out how rad i
was after i had already died
but that's why i was so busy filming to
make sure that they could do that
um and uh now
i think that when you become
famous you know like when you become
famous that it's impossible for there
not to be
i call it growing pains you know like
all of a sudden you've got bestowed upon
you all of this reverence all of this
power this influence and like it's just
human nature to abuse that you know to
like to you know you can now you can be
an [ __ ] now you can you can be
arrogant now you can you know and it's
like really hard to become famous and
not kind of go through these growing
pains of like to sort of not being the
best version of yourself yeah but
fortunately for you
you've
had the it's not like coming out of
nowhere like you've been through the
growing pains with your experience so i
feel like you're ready for this i am
loved like i've been everything all
so much [ __ ] happened to me over the
years a lot
some funny ones and some mad ones and
like they've all bought brought me to
the place where i'm at now and i'm more
prepared than i ever have been i love it
years ago when i take it off to go to
the ufc i'm so glad i said no because
never mind physically i wasn't ready
mentally i mean i still look like a
little boy as well i still have the body
of a 15 year old boy
so i was still a child but it's all done
me in good stead like
now um i'll fight anyone know what i
mean
i don't care okay and but what about the
business of paddy about it because i
want you to be able to like really um
like
harness like all that's just potential
that you have right honestly i know it
it's not just fighting for me
i'm going to be in are you i'm going to
be in films tv shows face-up brands like
that i know all right let's man let's
make it happen
i'm so impressed by your manager graham
that i gotta believe that behind the
scenes that this is already kind of
taking taking shape yeah it is honest
there's also going on behind the scenes
let's look at let's look at what sorry
that was a bad interrupt
but
let's look at what sean o'malley is
doing like when sean o'malley has a
fight going he's got like ready to go
like uh limited edition like for that
fight like march and he's [ __ ]
killing him yeah he is like that's what
i mean that's why
a lot of people should like follow would
watch sean those only a lot of fighters
should take a leaf out of his book but
instead do you want to sit down and talk
[ __ ] about i don't know what i mean
that's what oh dude shannon allie's the
man yeah he's cool i i like sean
i've been i've met him now
he's a nice dude he's a he's a cool dude
so i don't but people are always he's
like me he's a polarizing figure people
are always going to talk [ __ ] about him
love just like they are with me i'm used
to it just like he's used to it now
being happening he is with him just like
i was with me yeah
are you facetiming sean i'm [ __ ] face
type and facetiming sugar shawn
i think he's always picked up when it
when i have
but
this will be the scouse accents funny
[ __ ] i'm saying
you had
one of you guys had said something
somewhat disparaging of the other and
then and then you met yeah it was me
someone asked me something a long time
ago in an interview
and i said so what did i say
i said like oh he's a bit of a [ __ ] ass
though when he saw along them and it was
because of
when there's a
the fight with cheeto whether he says he
never lost thought
i criticized him for that yeah but him
and like obviously did i have to say
that i said something else about him
when i never know what i mean the way
interviewers just like that's one thing
what really annoys me
journalists
just twist what you say like it's all
clickbait yeah i remember someone asked
me something about the podium oliveira
fight and i was like oliveira's
unbelievable blah blah
but i said like i said something like
i personally believe if i was in that
position on dustin podium on his back
that i'd submit to myself
and the
the headline become paddy the body
thinks he'd beat us emporia yeah but
never said that none of me i never said
that
i said if i was on his back with a body
triangle locked in it's crazy i would
submit him if i had that much time left
on the clock i would because that's my
position that's what i'm good at but
the reporter changed it to our
paddleboard he said he'll beat when i
never never said it'd be dustin party
you know what i mean just as i say
reporters and not do my head then
they asked some shitty stupid questions
yeah a lot of the time
um
yeah dude you should facetime john jones
yeah he
loved it he's probably had four numbers
he is
the goal for me and then you've got like
your gsp and anderson silva behind them
but they don't always get forgot about
for me let's see those absolutely
unbelievable watching him in like the
early 2000s i've never seen anything
like it no and there's like pride and
obviously he was
pla proud of being bob by the time i
started watching the ufc so i i was
always watching that in the past yeah
and
lad
dude just the way you could put it all
together it was just shitty just arm
barring [ __ ] dudes that are like
100 pounds heavier than you you know
it's scary though yeah
all right dude before jon jones doesn't
pick up dude is there anything we wanted
what a guy
yeah dude i just don't know what
happened there man we were we were like
[ __ ] bros
and then i just never heard from him
again hopefully he sees this and he
reaches out yeah we miss you john jones
we had such a good time at your house
yeah
bones dude
yeah there we go
all right
no basically i'm everyone knows where to
find me love i always say that's just
i'm not on twitter no [ __ ]
would have kicked me off there so
i remember that the day before the night
before me fight as well i was there when
i tweeted on the ufc i am entertained
yeah like i was trying to tag you and i
couldn't tell me you can't take me
such a cool dude yeah we were chilling
with him the other week in chicago
watching the fight someone jamal hill
thought yeah we're watching them fights
with him in chicago
and we went to elton john with him the
night before it was a good little trip
to chicago that was good chicago is fun
yeah there we were at [ __ ]
romero whitaker ii
right in [ __ ] chicago in june 2018.
was it when
as a fighter i like kobe's good very
good but
as a person needs a piece of [ __ ] lad
yeah i mean i totally act as well like
just be yourself bro
right right here's the problem with
colby covington is that
they say oh it's just an act he's
actually the nicest guy
he's really a good guy well good guys
don't put on that kind of
a piece of [ __ ] if you put on that
exactly i've heard a few people say that
myself oh he's nice you know when you're
watching
nice people don't say oh i boned this
chick yeah don't [ __ ] have a go to
download
though even though i will give cover
covens and credit for [ __ ] shot being the
funniest oh yeah i've ever heard about
that yeah
that was a good one for them crash my
who do you think wins in a fight colby
or uh edwards
ah that's a flood
that's probably the most interesting
fight to see at world's elite
it's also a problem they sent the most
boring fight to see what you're watching
no they're just gonna [ __ ] punch each
other's faces in well no i called we
would scientific headstart colby
wouldn't stand with that but probably
knows full well what that would just do
to him
quality cycle yeah
edward
he's put up a nice dude
oh the nicest dude's got one on yeah i'd
love to see him win the belt
obviously me
my head's going with husband because
he's got more tools to win us one could
just sit on top for five rounds if he
wanted to or push him against the keys
are you done with woodley for five
rounds this one's huge
that's what i'm thinking no i'm
seriously thinking steve oh usman's
gonna think i've been beating everyone
up on the feet i might i'll be able to
stand with leon and leon might just
piece them up know what i mean i know
but i don't i think he's got a good
fight he was one and he wouldn't do that
did you see us jab against burns that
was the most [ __ ] powerful that was
against a man with a smaller reach
that's somebody had a reach advantage
over he hasn't over
and when it comes to kicks it's all
edwards okay i feel like hans power
edwards is the equivalent of covington
exactly it's harder than covington yeah
covington rock
in the second fight yeah i
i'll be honest i thought that fight
could have been a draw me
i'm not missing us when definitely 10 8
in the second and won the first but then
three four and five all could have went
to colby four and five definitely it was
how you scored the third it was good and
i should say i'm not i don't i'm not a
colby fan yeah i mean and i but you know
what here's the thing i also thought
zang wade beat rose that night as well
[Applause]
madison square garden judges
snud
i [ __ ] enjoy disliking colby
covington so much that i want him to win
every time so that i can keep having him
to enjoy disliking
now he hasn't got a fight has he i don't
think
it's getting embarrassing for moswell to
say i'm gonna break your face
like i saw a mask without on some sort
of podcast saying i can't like saying
like i got asked about me he said
something like english people can't
wrestle
what
english people can't wrestle pop cattle
black
jesus
don't ever like vlog
dude unbelievable thank you so much for
this and thank you for uh
you rented out a bar
yeah we've got it here we're having a
little watch party tonight for the ufc
aren't we that they'll be me you a
few few of the bad days are coming over
after they've played tonight as well i
think so be funny i'll just be sitting
in the corner
yeah
[Music]
how embarrassing like they're calling
people they don't pick up
oh well
she gets offline
that's staying in that's the funniest
thing to end on
now little did i know when i recorded
this episode with patty the baddie that
the very next morning
the very next morning we did his podcast
too
and man i think it might have
might have been better i don't know
different
both [ __ ] epic so
click on
my
episode of paddy the baddies podcast
well you didn't click yet
all right dude it's show time